russia's invasion of ukraine hit global
markets hard overnight oil prices topped
100 a barrel for the first time since
2014. for more on this and what it means
for your family's finances we're joined
by cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger jill good morning good
morning so what does this mean for
americans on things like prices of gas i
think that's where we're going to see
the most severe impact because we know
the price of oil has already been going
up we've seen oil and gas prices up by
40 from a year ago we're headed higher
unfortunately according to aaa we're at
about 3.54 cents nationally for a gallon
of gas if this persists if this goes on
we could see oil and gas prices utility
prices up even more we also could see
agricultural prices for wheat and corn
because russia and ukraine are big
exporters and finally we could see metal
prices when we look at iron ore we look
at palladium used in those chips that we
need in cars so all this is going to add
to inflationary pressures at least in
the short term and speaking of inflation
the inflation rate is at nearly a
40-year high so what does this conflict
mean for things like the price of food
well i think that what we're seeing
right now is at seven and a half percent
inflation we were expecting to drift a
little bit higher i'm talking to
economists who say this could go up to
nine percent inflation so everything is
going to cost more this of course puts
the federal reserve in a terrible bind
here's why because they want to raise
interest rates to control prices that's
important but at the same time this is a
conflict that could cause a lot of
economic damage and so the fed is
weighing not raising rates too quickly
to slow down the economic recovery but
trying to control those prices speaking
of the economic damage will the global
markets bounce back and what advice do
you give to investors well i always
start with try to take a deep breath
it's scary these panic situations are
really rough and try to just calm down
remain true to your plan markets are
going to be volatile so even if they are
exactly if they go down big today they
could go up big tomorrow try not to
react stick to that game plan remember
if you're a long-term investor these
moments are real tests so please try to
stay calm and try to remind yourself i'm
in it for the long term real quick what
about to consumers i think for consumers
just be prepared we are going to see
this level of high prices for a while
whether it's gas whether it's oil
whether it's food whether it's the chips
for your cars we are stuck with high
prices at least for a few more months
and maybe for as much as six months
depending on how long this escalation
lasts joe we appreciate this is valuable
information all right joe schlesinger
thank you